hello and welcome back now an exclusive
poll by ipsos for Sky News has found
that public support for UK sanctions on
Russia remains strong but could erode if
the cost of living crisis intensifies or
Kieran Pedley is research director for
rip Source the company which carried out
the survey and joins us now Karen good
morning thanks very much for being with
us let's just bring up some of the stats
that we've got and just talk our way
through these ones to bring up the first
uh graphic now
um so look the theories of course that
there is that perhaps going to be a
change in the UK government UK public
support for the Royal Ukraine should
things get worse
yes and so one of the things we've been
tracking over the course of the year is
is is that is how much support there is
for economic sanctions I think what you
can see on screen here is back in March
78 supported economic sanctions against
Russia um but now that's Fallen to 70
now there's two points I would raise on
this particular graphic the first is
that whilst there has been an
eight-point decrease in support that has
not manifested itself in an increase in
opposition to sanctions so only eight
percent are actually opposed and I think
we have to put this in the wider context
of the rising cost of living at the
moment there is strong public support
for the people of Ukraine people are
very concerned about civilians and this
is a this is a topic that's very much
captured the imagination of the British
people so whilst there has been a slight
softening and support for sanctions as
the years gone by in absolute terms
seven and ten in support is a lot of
people and you describe it as a
softening don't you it hasn't exactly
Fallen away falling off a cliff but I
guess it's to be expected eight months
into a war isn't it that is affecting us
here in many ways as well yes I think
one of the things we do see in the
numbers is that people do see make take
the link between the war and the rising
cost of living here so when we say on a
range of topics you know which which of
these topics are contributing towards
the rising cost of living at the moment
1810 acknowledge that the Russian
invasion of Ukraine is contributing
towards the cost of living increase
alongside things like government policy
or interest rates and other things as
well so they do recognize that the war
is causing a rise in the cost of living
but there is still strong support for
the people of Ukraine nonetheless okay
let's bring up the next graphic here and
we'll talk our way through this this one
now the question is would you support
continuing economic sanctions against
Russia even if they led to increased
energy prices in the UK
so obviously one of the questions that
people always ask is okay people support
sanctions now but what will happen in
the future if the cost of living crisis
increases increases to worsen and what
we found in March was that 73 said no we
still support economic sanctions even if
Energy prices rise but of course they
have been rising over the course of the
year so what we find today is that
that's Fallen to 41 saying they would
continue to support sanctions should the
cost of energy prices increase and you
can see that the proportions that are
opposed in that situation has risen to a
third I mean would you would you
describe that as softening was that
eroding that looks like it's Fallen
quite a long way so at face value it
looks like a sharp decrease but what I
would say is that this is in the context
of where prices have been so back in
March when we asked this question prices
were obviously significantly lower than
they are today I think the important
point the important Nuance here is that
whilst that does look like a significant
drop and it is in absolute terms as I've
just explained there's still seven in
ten supporting sanctions at the moment
this is about what happens if prices
continue to increase now at the moment
there's the energy price cap of course
so that won't happen in the immediate
term we think but of course next spring
we might see a different story yeah it's
one I guess for government to be mindful
if they can in some way keep those
prices down let's bring up the last
Square because we can care and talk our
way through this now the question here
was to what extent would you say you are
concerned about the impact of the
Russian invasion on and then we've got a
list of options there Ukrainian
civilians the UK economy UK National
Security or oneself yes I think the
important Point here is that okay people
are concerned about yes uh the UK
economy and UK National Security and
that's to be expected with all the
discussion about potential escalation to
a nuclear conflict in the future but
what you can see on this graphic is the
most strongest level of concern is for
the Ukrainian people themselves 47 of
the public say they're very concerned
about the impact of the conflict on
Ukrainian civilians and this goes back
to what we were saying at the beginning
but I think this has captured the
imagination of people they've seen the
pictures on screen and that's manifested
itself in support for uh for for those
sanctions but of course that support
isn't necessarily Limitless so if the
cost of living crisis increases to buy
if prices increase then that then that
we might see that support soften further
in the future but for now really
important to stress the pub the British
public are behind the Ukrainian people
and support those sanctions so perhaps
that I do with wolf teigas is overplayed
somewhere all right Kieran for now thank
you very much appreciate the research
thank you